mais non voir son nom sur la liste c'est
la seule chose qui compte
à cet instant là on est content parce
que si les frères on attendait le bas
qui est au final on n'a pas passé mais
on l'a quand même c'est on est de
déstresser jack tv mal parti au début
avec le coronavirus le confinement de sa
balle à les soulager
c'est que du positif cette année pas
d'explosion de joie ni de cris mais sous
les masques de grands sourires et du
soulagement fait mention assez bien
donc c'est bien d'avoir le bac avec ces
conditions particulières même si on n'a
pas eu le stress de faire les épreuves
va on est content d'avoir été admis
comme ça et on s'en est bien sorti
dernières heures au lycée
épilogue d'une drôle d'année un moment
important aussi pour les parents déjà
c'est pas une année comme les autres et
en plus bas on sait que du coup c'était
une année porteuse de ses fruits parce
qu'elle a travaillé pour dur pour
arriver là donc c'est parfait on est
heureuses mais les vacances ne sont pas
pour tout le monde
entre 8 et 10 sur 20 et les candidats
sont bons pour le rattrapage
je sais que je suis pas très loin de
l'avoir dit
dans tous les cas
autour des cages mais après c'est une
question dont les oraux sont prévues
mercredi et vendredi